ludovic emmanuelli est avec nous
président de l' ong croissance peas et
expert des relations entre l'afrique et
l'europe
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation il ya sept ans l'union
africaine avait déjà promis je cite de
mettre un terme à toutes les guerres en
afrique
en 2020 on y est le thème du sommet qui
s'ouvre demain ils suivent en faire
taire les armes sur le continent
africain
décidément c'est un voeu pieux la paix
sur le continent
la paix sas mais encore faut-il y
accéder donc actuellement effectivement
beaucoup de travail je pense que si ça
ne tenait qu'à l'afrique
il y aurait la paix mais il ya un
certain nombre de puissances étrangères
et autres qui sont en train de se
démarquer et qui entretiennent parfois
un climat qui n'est pas forcément le
meilleur
si on prend l'exemple de la certaine
poser la question pour la libye la libye
sont des puissances étrangères qui ont
attaqué la libye et les conséquences sur
l'afrique sont considérables au point de
vue social économique humanitaire
ce sont les étrangers qui ont attaqué
cette libye et malheureusement l'union
africaine ne s'est pas imposé pour
pouvoir stopper ce genre de dantec et
comment est ce que vous l'expliquer que
l'union africaine ne parviennent pas à
imposer sa voix alors l'union africaine
est soumise à un certain nombre de
divergences de par les chefs d'état qui
traitent avec des présidents étrangers
ou des institutions ou des organisations
internationales qui n'ont pas forcément
les mêmes altéré enfin l'intérêt pour
l'afrique est bien gros intérêts
financiers et l'afrique n'arrive pas
pour le moment à se se maîtriser alors
pour se maîtriser
il pourrait y avoir quelques quelques
pistes d'ailleurs je vous donnais
puisque c'est des petites indiscrétions
que j'ai pu avoir le made in africa qui
est en train d'essayer de se faire c'est
à dire avoir un label qui pourrait
permettre aux africains de privilégier
le madoff made in africa également
quelque chose de fondamental qui est en
train de se développer et où la primaire
a été donnée à lomé au togo par une
maison
du savoir et des opportunités en clair
c'est quoi c'est la possibilité pour les
africains de maîtriser leur futur qui
passe par les inventions
donc si on invente africain on peut
maîtriser à la fois sa production et on
peut maîtriser son sens futur parce que
finalement s'attaquer aux défis
économiques socio économique c'est aussi
tenter d'apaiser les tensions
les violences c'est ça le fond du
problème le son du bois il ya deux
problèmes il ya la paix qui est
fondamental plus il ya de paix plus à
des gens qui vivent heureux sur place et
qui développent leur pays et qu'ils sont
heureux de développer et ensuite il ya
développement la prospérité
l'un peut aller avec l'autre mais il
faut encore accorder ses violons et
l'histoire de la zone de libre échange
qui est en train de se créer est une
excellente idée
une excellente idée il va falloir
construire c'est pas facile on a
cinquante cinq chefs d'état qui ont pas
forcément les mêmes les mêmes visions la
même envie de se développer mais je suis
sûr que les africains dans leur
intelligence vont trouver des solutions
par eux-mêmes pour eux mêmes et la
solution peut donc être et ne peut être
qu économique selon vous elle peut être
économique mais il faut qu'elle soit
sécuritaire aussi il va falloir que
l'afrique soit contrôlée par des
africains au niveau sécurité et ça c'est
sûr des progrès ont toutefois été
enregistrées dernièrement en afrique ou
encore au soudan
oui enfin il ya en afrique il ya des
problèmes le soudan il ya des évolutions
qui sont plutôt positives mais il ya
toujours des morts ce qu'il faut c'est
ralentir ce nombre de morts et faire en
sorte que dans chaque pays il y est les
entités qui puisse discuter ensemble et
favoriser ce ce climat de paix et faire
en sorte que les intérêts de la paix
soit supérieur aux intérêts financiers
de manière ensuite à recréer de la
prospérité
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de ce
sommet de l'union africaine qui s'ouvre
demain et pour deux jours
non déjà une grande chose c'est que les
présidents se rencontrent quand on
discute on peut évoluer
on peut travailler ensemble et à partir
de là je suis sûr que bientôt vous allez
avoir de d'excellentes nouvelles venant
de ce fabuleux continent qui vont
permettre à la fois de trouver des
moyens de rétablir la paix petit à petit
le dernier la dernière présidence
égyptienne n'a pas forcément donné de
bons résultats
actuellement l'afrique du sud a envie de
faire quelque chose j'espère qu'on va
trouver des solutions pour éradiquer le
terrorisme et en éradiquant le
terrorisme on arrivera à faire de
grandes choses en afrique et c'est à eux
mais très concrètement qu'est ce que
vous attendez des déclarations
spécifiques
demain après demain alors des
déclarations il y en aura toujours
savez l'afrique comme les autres pays du
monde on aura toujours de bonnes
déclarations
le tout c'est qu'ils arrivent à
concrétiser leurs envies et leurs
déclarations qu'elles vont être très
positive maintenant il faut y aller
l'union africaine a encore un vrai rôle
à jouer
abbas et un rôle fondamental et vous
allez voir dans les prochaines années on
ne parlera plus que de l'union africaine
merci un beau coup ludovic emmanuelli
président de l'om j'ai croissance peas
et expert des relations entre l'afrique
et l'europe
[Musique]